the Joe Rogan experience you'd think
it's like something that people should
experience um I think that's up to
people yeah a good play I know we have
to be careful where we say to people but
I understand but yeah I used to think
people need to do it I think people I
used to think people need to do
everything I think you do whatever and
also having children there's a lot of
people that say you should have children
I don't know about that man I think
everybody has a different path I think
you can be a complete person without
ever having children I don't I don't
think that that's necessary for me it
was very educational it helped me a lot
I loved it I'm very happy to be a father
and a lot but I don't think it's
necessary I think you can be a complete
person without a lot of experiences I
think what's more important is like what
kind of experiences are you having with
the people that you're around with and
are you being fulfilled like if you
inherently like inside of you you always
wanted to be a chess master but you
never pursued it you're gonna have that
regret and that longing for something
for you that way if you didn't pursue
that if you didn't go after that if you
instead decided to get a job in
accounting or something like that you
would have this longing to do something
and I think everyone has a different
makeup a different psychological makeup
different personnel and different
interests and I think there's a lot of
people that are interested in things
that I have no desire to do and to them
it's their whole life and I'm not
interested in at all but I'm not them
it's like finding out what it is what it
is for you what what is it in your life
that attracts you I've been very very
very fortunate and one of the things
that I've been very fortunate is I I'm I
would say I'm a risk taker but it's more
that I don't I don't have any interest
in doing safe things okay in terms of
like I don't have any interest in like
taking an easy job a safe job I know I'm
gonna get a paycheck every week that's
never interests me yeah that seems like
prison yeah I really I've never been
able to do it and I always thought that
I was a loser because I couldn't do that
because other people could work hard and
they can get a good job and they would
get security I felt like when I was
young there's something wrong with me
that I couldn't do that because I grew
up in New England and then
Boston everybody worked hard this is
like a hard blue-collar sort of
environment wherever I couldn't do it
man I couldn't do it these guys all
showed up for work every day at 7:00
a.m. I wanted to kill myself did you do
it a little bit I did a lot of
construction gig yes and a lot of
different small jobs but the reason same
reason why I left because I felt like it
was missing something I see the world I
wanted to be yes that's you though but
look now you're fulfilled
you're a fulfilled person you're living
your life but that's you your other
person that would be torture if you had
some guy that really just wants to be a
mathematician and someone's like no no
you're gonna go to Myanmar you're gonna
be a [ __ ] left wait champion you'd be
like what what I'm not head-butting
anybody there's a [ __ ] you're not man
better cuz I gotta head but you know
you're gonna fight in prison what's what
I'm not fighting in prison for the
record because I wasn't incarcerated
right was in prison but that you know
everyone has their own path some people
like do you know Alex Honnold is he's
the guy who they made that movies free
solo about he's the the guy who climbs
all these mountains with no ropes oh my
god yeah any fell and he got disfigured
but I was healing up but he didn't know
rope how far did he fall look I have to
shoot a picture he was a bad fall it was
about he looked like he got bitten by a
dog and yeah I guess they look for a
rush that's an amazing Russian it was
good I think so but uh Alex the way he
described it he said it's not really a
rush he said it's pretty mellow okay
because if every if you get a rush like
you're in trouble actual you know it's
like the whole thing but it's obviously
there's something about that intense
challenge that's appealing to him that
doesn't attract me at all not even a
little bit I have no [ __ ] desire I
don't want to even climb with ropes but
this guy loves it did you do bungee
before I did you try bunch no never
don't let either now [ __ ] why not some
people love it man I get it I get look
my friend Andy he's a world champion
he's that he holds the world record in
flying one of those winged suits my
friend Andy stomp that was a goal of
mine for a while but he's had a bunch of
friends of
man they've had to carry them off the
mountain because they [ __ ] hit the
ground you know guys who have jumped and
then they hear a crash and then they
realize that guy just slammed into a
[ __ ] tree or there's a really
horrible video slam into a bridge
oh he's trying to go through a bridge
who's trying to make it through the gap
of a bridge and he misjudged he slammed
right into the bridge while these people
were on it filming it you see him come
in and just misjudges it and bam he hits
the bridge it's horrific man if he has a
strong neck he's fine see I think
everybody is different some people are
put on this life to be poet some people
put on this right to be an author
describe put on this life now I mean
whoever you are okay how you feel what
is what is the thing that you're drawn
to for some people its architecture they
want to build houses they're fascinated
by the construction methods they're
fascinated by design and they're just
really drawn to want to build houses
yeah some people want to make music some
people are drawn to lyrics and they're
drawn to musical notes and bars and
changes and that's their thing everybody
has a I mean some people have many
things you know and then something
something for some people that's their
problem is they have so many things it's
hard to focus on one but really the key
I think the happiness in life is fight
being honest with yourself and finding
whatever it is that's attractive to you
yeah whatever it is it draws you whether
it's animation or sculpture or making
clothes but it's everyone has a thing
while you were talking there I would I
feel like I was another dimension I felt
like it was like I lost myself really
yeah that's the effect I was like I
don't know I'm thinking I think I'm I
think I'm crazy yeah you're definitely
crazy to be really great at me like
you're like you're doing something and
then you have the feeling like you don't
know I don't know you carried away yeah
you're getting carried away and the
thoughts yeah I have that all the time
it's a crazy life yeah it is a crazy
life but it's a really crazy life if you
follow your passions yeah and it's a
[ __ ] crazy boring life if you don't
we'll set and there's a lot of people
out there that unfortunately whether
it's their family yeah sometimes your
family they they'll try to influence you
in a way too
get you to do something that's safer I
mean my own family did that they were
always trying to get me to the big one
was graduate from college graduate from
university get a degree you know have a
safe you know don't just try to how'd
you do comedy because I know Gary Vee is
a big proponent of that like you know
quit school and I might and how do you
do like cuz a lot of people are stuck
with the parents think so you just said
[ __ ] it I'm gonna do it or cuz with ya I
think my parents gave up on trying to
control me very young you know like they
didn't even want me to do martial arts
when I started doing martial arts when
he didn't start really heavily when I
was fifteen I started when I was
fourteen but really heavily when I was
fifteen that's when I just became
obsessed with Taekwondo and competing
and and you know at first they didn't
want me to do it but then that was like
the first thing that I ever did that
made me feel like I wasn't a loser yeah
I was like the first thing that ever did
that I got really good at like good at
and like started getting recognition
from it and started winning tournaments
and then I realized like wow if I focus
on something and become obsessed with
something I can get really good at it
yeah so that led to learning how to do
that in applying that sort of same
energy to other things in life you know
I think sometimes people just have to
find a thing whatever that thing is that
really floats your boat and then find
the time find the time to pursue it and
set up your life so that you have the
time to pursue it and now they're scarce
elevated if I do this isn't it there's
not gonna be income around just a
percent and money will come and yes yeah
everything is possible I think and it's
crazy that but I know that I kind of
lived it it's true you can do it you can
do whatever you want
[Applause]